talking about hello to the year of the
tiger bianca holman is live at the asian
community development council as we say
goodbye to the year of the ox so i found
out i'm the year of the pig bianca year
of the pig nate you are uh rooster
brewster yep
what does that mean for us and i'm the
year
yes well i'm not quite sure we're gonna
have to google it but i'm also the year
of the tiger so
but a lot of people you know when it
comes to the lunar new year they think
of the chinese culture but it's in fact
several asian countries celebrate the
lunar new year matter of fact vietnam
it's a huge celebration and holiday
there so we were actually able to meet
up with a group that told us more about
the holiday and how they celebrated
there in vietnam it's actually called
tet a short name which means feast of
the first morning so here in las vegas
there are more than 40 thousand
vietnamese people and that number is
growing lunar new year is a time to
forget the past and look forward to the
hope and good luck for the upcoming year
everybody wants the whole year happy so
they have to be happy in the first day
otherwise it's not good so everybody
happy they will say
a lot of wish to you wish you
health
more money happiness everything good
happened in the ted festival
yes we are all wanting that good health
wealth and happiness so the group of
viet nevada culture is hosting an event
this weekend their help they have helped
so many people so many vietnamese people
adjust to life here in the valley and
they've provided them with resources
especially at the height of the pandemic
and they want you to celebrate with them
it starts at 1 pm it's free to enter
it's going to be at the clark county
amphitheater and there's going to be
food plenty of food vendors authentic
items from vietnam and entertainment
including the traditional dragon dance
if you haven't seen it you definitely
want to go to at least that event or one
of the others around the valley to see
that dance it's so energetic and again
it makes you be happy and excited about
what's to come so coming up in the next
half hour i'm definitely going to share
more about the event that's coming up on
this sunday i'm going to send it back to
you guys in the studio all right thanks
so much bianca look forward to it
beautiful celebrations for sure